tda ou dahchour avocat au barreau de
paris bonjour merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors de quels
constats sont partis les parlementaires
à l'initiative de cette proposition de
loi sécurité globale effectivement il y
avait un débat un moment sur la la
question de la représentation des prises
de vue des policiers par deux
manifestations il y avait une remontée
on va dire des listes radicales le
policière sur un danger de deux prises
de vue lors de manifestations qui s'est
il de pouvoir générer des risques
les deux autres côté du point de vue
effectivement notamment désir et je
cible de certains représentants des
droits et des libertés
on estime que et bien effectivement si
les policiers ne peuvent plus être
filmés lors des manifestations
lorsqu'ils commettent des autres qui met
pas vu des violences policières
eh bien ça on pourrait plus en apporter
la preuve
voyez donc là il ya un double départ
d'un côté on nous parle de sécurité dont
des forces de police lors des
interventions des manifestations et de
l'autre le côté on nous dit ben écoute
et oui le coeur du problème fait de
pouvoir voir les les agents police
lorsqu'ils commettent des infractions
il faut bien comprendre que où on a un
vrai problème en france voulait que dans
un sac rempli notamment des pays anglo
saxons cette question là il déjà pioché
c'est à dire que notamment aux états
unis depuis très longtemps il ya des
caméras qui sont embarqués dans les
voitures de police il ya des caméras qui
filment
donc les policiers en action donc c'est
une prof qui elle même constituée par
les forces de la police a donc donc
c'est pour ça qu'il faut effectivement
ça veut dire que bon on est peut-être
dans quelque chose qui est très
franco-français et et qui en fait est
certainement beaucoup plus simple que ce
qu'on joue à condé on est soumis
actuellement quand même comme prévu non
vous êtes avocat
que pensez-vous de la réécriture de
l'article 24
comment appréciez vous cette nouvelle
version alors effectivement on est
encore dans ça va quand même pas qu'on
est encore dans la navette
donc cela n'avait c'est la circulation
du texte entre le sénat et l'assemblée
donc c'est à dire que le texto d'une
chambre à l'autre et il subit des
modifications laquelle modifications
effectivement semble revenir sur le sur
le choix qui était le premier qui était
savoir de protéger les forces de police
de prise de vue de manifestations mais
pour autant il faut bien avoir l'esprit
que pour l'instant le texte est adopté
il ya que sa publication au journal
officiel qui va faire qu'il a rencontré
en mai khai et donc tant qu'on n'a pas
entendu quand on est encore sur un
projet toi qui subit des modifications
selon la circulation l'objectif donc que
peut pas encore être certain de sa
rupture finale alors autre article on
permet de l'article 24 gars également
l'article 25 qui fait polémique
il maintient le port d'armes pour les
policiers en dehors de leurs heures de
service
est ce que c'est un faux débat comme
certains vont dire puisque c'est une
disposition qui existait déjà plus ou
moins
ou est-ce que c'est plutôt comme
d'autres le dire on dérive autoritaire
sécuritaire cette histoire elle a déposé
après le règlement on avait là
effectivement des policiers qui avait
été victime lors des attentats pouvant
et on avait
évoquer le fait qu'il n'était pas armé
et il y avait eu la question à savoir si
les principaux pas être armés l'offre de
services en l'état c'est pas quelque
chose sur lequel on a un retour
d'expérience à mesure on n'a pas cette
tradition en france donc on n'a pas si
vous voulez pour l'instant de
manifestations dont entre guillemets de
bavures policières là dessus les
mauvaises interventions avec les armes
qui ont lieu ces d'impression en service
à dire c'est l'hypothèse où des
policiers étaient en tenue ou en civil
mais dans l'eure dans leurs fonctions de
deux policiers à utiliser leur arme et
pour l'instant on n'a pas de wild
feedback de retour là dessus donc pour
l'instant le débat est très théorique et
tous les goûts on n'a pas vraiment de
retour de manière pour l'instant que
c'est quelque chose de forcément mauvais
ou de bons jeunes et on ne sait pas tout
ce que ce que ça va donner ça mais ce
qui est certain c'est que si on arme les
policiers ont quand même plusieurs
années y compris entre guillemets dans
leur visibilité dans leur vie
quotidienne
ce qu'il faudrait faire c'est par contre
augmenté notamment la possibilité pour
eux de s'entraîner dans au tir passe
comme ça c'est aussi un problème
récurrent des moyens la police nationale
la gendarmerie c'est qu'il s'entraîne
pas à ses hôtes ils n'ont pas assez
management la possibilité s'intégrer
quand vous parlez policiers c'est un
débat récurrent et où le dise il peut
pas s'entraîner à ces avec les armes et
donc je pense que si on va dans sa
démarche la moindre des choses c'est par
contre une action de formation sur lui à
des armes dans 2h remercie d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat au barreau de paris et
marseille